well guys we have officially come to the
Batman and Robin of the Superman
franchise in our continuing
collaboration between the schmoes and
myself we've been reviewing all the
Superman movies before Man of Steel
comes out I hope you guys have been
enjoying all of these videos today on my
channel we're going to be talking about
Superman for the quest for peace
take it away schmoes alright Chris
thanks for having us back in your
Channel sorry it has to be for these
circumstances it is Superman for the
quest for peace Christian I know you
can't wait to rip this movie to shreds
so before we do that I'm not going to
give you your dessert til eats his
vegetables here's the good things about
the quest for peace Jon Cryer's in it a
young Jon Cryer we get to see him
there's a guy named nuclear man it's
about ending the world of nuclear
weapons which is a good thing for kids
to see and it's got Christopher Reeve
and unfortunately his last turn as
Superman and it's uh you know that you
listed know good things you know said
absolutely know good things this was the
last one that poor Christopher Reeve did
that is a negative Jon Cryer a younger
crier is a good thing nice hair dummy
and his stupid voice was horrendous
nuclear man that's the best at all the
comics nuclear Ram are you kidding it's
a really thin silver lining you gotta
really look hard to see you know it's
weird to say this was probably the movie
I saw the most of my childhood just cuz
it was on more than all the other ones
so I'm most familiar with Superman for
the crossword piece and I'm thinking
when people look back on the Christopher
Reeve Superman's this and Superman 3
infiltrate their heads too much because
of how campy they got I'm gonna defend
the quest for peace in this regard is
that I always feel bad for movies when
they have this big epic thing that they
want to try to do and then they had
these budget constraints because they
had to cut so many corners in production
having said all that the plot the script
everything about this movie is really
stupid it's bastardizing everything that
Superman originally stood for
I don't feel bad for any of this movie
because it's the idiot producers that
decided all we're going to be cheap and
cut corners here I mean everything with
this movie is cheap and horrible the
story is horrendous it's so stupid and
ridiculous
it's a bad Saturday morning cartoon it's
the Batman and Robin of the series it's
spider-man 3 it is crap a fart box on
wheels a stink pile with a piss platter
and a fart served on the side it is so
bad it makes me angry so you liked it
yeah
no it sucks and here here you go so
right away you're in space you got the
Russians good Superman's flying around
he helps the Russians and then you're
back into metropolis you're with Lois
Lane and guess what some kid gets pissed
off and says oh we got to stop the nukes
and he sends them to eat and doesn't
send an email wish it was send an email
he sends a letter to Superman and
Superman decides is going to get
involved and gives the worst speech
you've ever seen ever in the UN and said
I'm gonna get rid of all the nuclear
weapons it really did take out a take
you from like rocky 4 Oh looks like
where they watched rocky 4 year earlier
they're like oh this could kind of you
know maybe this yield the United States
and Russia so now we'll make a movie
trying to end nuclear weapons it's so
dumb yeah the Jon Cryer seems ridiculous
he plays Lex Luthor's nephew and he's
horrible to watch it and they for the 87
time Lex Luthor breaks out of prison
decides in a steel strand of Superman's
hair all right yeah what isn't Lex
Luthor like in solitary Hannibal Lector
confinement at this point he's he's
really good at breaking out of jail
oh so dumb and then he basically takes a
piece of the hair puts it into some crap
and into a nuclear weapon get Superman
to throw it into the Sun and then Dolph
Lundgren with the wig comes flying out
there man that's the voice of Gene
Hackman a nuclear man comes back and
you're right of all the villains that
Superman could have fought against we
got a deal with this guy not only do I
have to fight him on planet Earth we got
to lock him in a damn elevator shaft
earth and throw him to the dark side of
the Moon which is where this movie
belongs they Duke it out and then
Superman comes back then Superman comes
back and then Superman's got to go to
the moon and then Superman has to move
the Earth's gravitational he moves the
moon he'd remember the first one we flew
around the earth is like wait what now
he moves them I don't care what planet
you were born on Adrian Peterson could
not move the moon the special effects
also in this movie planted the dinosaur
looks like inception there talk bad
about plan I'm not I gave it a
compliment I said how good it looks
compared to Superman for Superman for is
an abomination of a film it really it's
horrible it was a cheap grab for money
it made um it really ruined everything
that was great about 1 & 2 because you
because that was the one that was fresh
in your head and almost it killed it for
years and years and years but again
using the same thing that we've used in
the past had this crap box never
happened we would have never got the
evolution to where we are now trying to
spend a positive here it's horrible
there's nothing positive except
fact christopher reeve is in the costume
so i'll give it a half
I don't live I'm gonna give a solid
Schmo because if you're a little kid you
wear the nuclear weapons are bad and
they can cause a lot of destruction and
that uh you you're a fish mom reaching
Jewish mom I don't Christopher Reeve
we're going to do Chris thanks for
having us for this one this is like
literally I felt like we were all being
tortured and waterboarded watching this
thing so uh thanks for having us at your
place Chris I'm sorry he broke
everything
I'm sure Stockman did as well so thanks
again and then check out make sure you
check out on our channel Superman
Returns which we were reviewing on
Tuesday better than the quest for peace
not hard really nothing about this movie
works in every way it was a complete
failure and I really got to do is do a
little reading about this movie and
you'll see they were trying to make
something possibly good but the
production company behind this movie
just 100% was not invested enough which
is why every single effect shot in this
movie looks unfinished and you get that
same shot of Christopher Reeve flying
directly into the screen literally about
eight or nine times to quickly sum up
the plot of Superman for Superman
decides he's going to rid the earth of
all nuclear weapons based off of a
letter sent to him by some child who
wanted that to happen and gene Hackman
as Lex Luthor escapes from prison using
a strand of Superman's hair to create a
nuclear man he takes Superman's DNA then
shoots it into the Sun and then a
literal fetus of a the literal ECF fetus
like just form into nuclear man of
course nuclear man also has a mullet and
big press-on shiny Nails oh boy
right from the beginning this movie is
idiotic I can deal with the whole
there's no sound in space but movies
will sometimes have sound in space like
Star Wars I get it there's really no
sound in space but you know I would
prefer to see x-wings going to video do
than just silence you know what I mean
but Superman rescuing an astronaut and
then just speaking Russian to him and
flying away and everything it's just
it's all so stupid the way this movie
starts it's terrible
okay but that's just some one little
thing alright every scene in this movie
is so idiotic the way Lex Luthor creates
nuclear man in this movie is by taking a
strand of Superman's hair he steals it
from a museum then uses the DNA to
create nucular man now when we're
introduced to the strand of hair in the
Museum a tour guys going look at
Superman's strand of hair look at all of
the weight that is suspended on this one
single hair course it says 1,000 pounds
like it's a Looney Tunes weight that
actually said I might as well just say
Acme right beneath it Gene Hackman just
comes up breaks the glass and breaks the
hair with a hedge clipper apparently Man
of Steel's hair can suspend giant 1000
pound weights and also be made of steel
but hedge clippers break through it just
fine Wow
so as I said this kid writes Superman a
letter and this kid in school like he's
like this really mature kid like they're
talking about how they can cease war and
what the kid's thoughts on political
governments are in like second grade or
whatever this little kids just looking
out the window like all depressed and
everything and he's the mature kid
doesn't listen to anyone else he's like
I got my own thoughts and teachers like
hey kid what do you think about this and
then he just turns around goes I'll tell
you what should happen Superman Superman
should rid the world nuclear weapons
why doesn't he do something it's the
most obvious audio dubbed voice I've
ever heard in a movie I swear that's
what the voice sounds like so then we
get Christopher Reeve speech on nuclear
weapons we get the birth of nuclear man
and then a giant fight breaks out except
if you watch the deleted scenes to this
movie which by the way there are 40
minutes of deleted scenes with
unfinished special effects including a
prototype nuclear man that was created
before the real nuclear man who goes
around wreaking havoc and some people
are related him to their Superman
character bizarro but he's really just
some clown but he's gratefully not in
the actual movie thank goodness because
then it would have been even worse but
this seriously is 40 minutes of deleted
scenes where they cut out like stuff in
Russia they cut out stuff in other areas
where these guys go around fighting and
so the entire scene where they fight
like goes from space to the earth back
to space to other areas of space back to
earth again and it's the worst chopped
up editing I have ever seen you're
supposed to accept certain things happen
basically the majority of the fight is
like the Kirk vs. Gorn fight from the
original Star Trek show or they just
kind of hold each other and go in slow
motion quite a bit it's really one of
the worst things I've ever seen in my
life there is but one good thing
this movie and it's the one consistent
thing throughout these four movies that
was good and that is Christopher Reeve
Christopher Reeve is great as Superman
and he's good here even though his story
is just crumbling beneath him and if you
actually read Christopher Reeves
biography he just talks about how much
of a disaster this movie was like he was
like yeah I took one of the actors aside
before the movie came out and I
literally told him prepare yourself
because this is going to be an absolute
disaster basically prepare yourself to
get butt raped because Superman 4 is
going to ruin our lives for a while
Christopher Reeve hated this movie he
couldn't stand the fact the production
company that said they wanted to invest
in this movie took away like almost all
of their funds and they weren't even
able to finish the movie and they still
released it to the public like there's
so many unfinished things like nuclear
man looks at a newspaper and sees Lacey
the girl that's crushing after Clark and
goes hmm I like that world and just
decides to go find her he lands in front
of like The Daily Planet or something
and goes where is she by the way that's
gene Hackman's voice destroy Superman
and Superman lands in front of him and
goes he'll never find her how does he
know who he's even talking about don't
do it the people nucular man the people
of course nucular man eventually does
find LaCie and then takes her up into
space
yeah they fly into space she survives
entry into space with no oxygen
she also survives re-entry into Earth by
holding on the nucular man she's not
burnt up she can breathe just fine
she's just flying around in space
Superman for the quest for peace is a
terrible movie I am however going to
give it a d-minus simply because
Christopher Reeve is still good as
Superman I would have said one
consistent thing that's good throughout
this series is the music but John
Williams only composed the first film
after that it was just people imitating
his themes and the music for Superman
for is just this giant mishmash of his
themes imitated by someone else it's
very very annoying and kind of
disgraceful actually it's a terrible
terrible movie and I'm so glad I don't
to talk about it anymore
thanks a lot for watching guys stay
tuned for Superman Returns this Tuesday
that review is going to be on the
schmoes Channel enjoy that and as always
guys thanks for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck menage